welcome to the across the Spoilers
Podcast I'm your host Paul once more
joined by the biggest heavy spoilers fan
I've ever seen because you're rocking
that t-shirt it's Greg Alba how's it
going I feel bad we're on a call for 10
minutes beforehand I'm like this mother
f word has not brought up at all that
I've been wearing heavy spoiler shirt
this entire time and all I wanted was a
bit of recognition and now I got it so I
feel great my friend how are you how are
you I'm good yeah it's good it's good
chatting with you it's the highlight of
my week every week
um we're dropping this a day early
hopefully we've got I've got a big video
coming out tomorrow fingers crossed it's
been a crazy crazy weekend trying to get
the video ready we're dropping an hour
long
um Empire Strikes Back breakdown you
know people are hitting me up all the
time like oh I wish you'd we should go
back to just doing eight minute fun
videos and I'm like oh I've got some bad
news bad news about uh the Big Star Wars
video we're doing but looking at things
in general at the moment the movie
industry it's all over the place oh
things are getting hit with delays
the strikes are still ongoing we're
going to be breaking it all down in this
video and talking about this week's
biggest stories Greg have you got a
rundown I need a rundown of of
everything we're going to talk we got
delays we got box office and we have uh
the Avengers Riders they might be
getting it looks like they've been fired
like Jeff loveness and whatnot and
whoever the other guy is I don't know
look they're looking for new writers and
then of course we got wga updates which
Paul will give us the breakdown for Paul
will do all the breakdown and I'll be
here nodding my head going interesting
stuff what do you want to start with man
you want to start what we want to do
with the box office expert that's what
the internet knows you as do you want to
go through the box office first I hope
not yeah I will go through the box
office
um so yeah Super Mario Brothers movie is
now no longer the highest grossing movie
of the air because Bobby has overtaken
it and it's been absolutely crazy you
know they've just also announced that um
it's going to become going to IMAX for
one week only starting September 22nd
with a never before seen post credit
scene that's going to be shown and we I
still haven't seen Bobby unfortunately
and I hadn't seen yeah I hadn't seen
Mario for quite a while and they'll say
oh it's the biggest you know it's a
highest grossing movie there I better
just I'm gonna lose my my movie credit
credit movie critic credentials here if
I if I don't see it um but yeah still
haven't seen it unfortunately I might go
check the iMac screening uh yeah it's
absolutely killing it uh yeah that's
kind of crazy how we have this movie
podcast
and all we do is talk about the crap in
this industry we still haven't seen
Harvey I think that has drastically
effect what came out this weekend was it
Gran Turismo Gran Turismo finally
did it do okay
um I think it did 17 million do you have
the figures yeah you've got 17.3 million
uh with the domestics
fantastic here and of course directed by
Neil blomkamp but the movie has good
reviews for the most part I think
um yeah I feel like it'll probably have
a decent audience score and they they
actually had some sneak previews that
did okay I suppose wow Barbie is set to
become the biggest movie for Warner
Brothers right now surpassing Harry
Potter holy crap did you you know I knew
it would be a hit I knew you didn't
think it would be a hit but man this is
a way bigger hit than I ever expected it
to possibly be
Oppenheimer actually has a chance of
maybe it's it's almost at 800 million
Global it if it stays like this
I don't know that's a lot that's 200
million dollars more but if it stays in
the theater could you think it could
reach a billion that would be nuts well
the the prediction for its total um box
office run is 950 million really I think
it's going to close out doing
um and I've just actually bought a
ticket just to be a shill and help it
along a bit
um but yeah I mean if it hit the belly
and that would be absolutely insane
obviously this week they talked about
how it's now Christopher Nolan's highest
grossing original film so you know
things like the The Batman Trilogy and
stuff like that Dark Knight and Dark
Knight Rises they did insane numbers but
you know things Inception I think was
the next one on but it's now surpassed
that so it's sitting really well uh I
think it's an incredible film I think it
deserves it you know it's good to see
these two movies just Logan Paul doesn't
like it man Logan Paul has issues yeah I
mean he comes across like a guy who
really loves film and so I'm sure you
know it's fine if he doesn't like it I
can totally watch that movie and see why
a lot of people wouldn't but just
thinking about it I mean it's a biopic
set in the 1940s that doesn't really
have any action scenes and lots of
things in black and white and for it to
do that much money is absolutely insane
I think it shows the clout that
Christopher Nolan has
um and this is really gonna Skyrocket it
on one of the podcast episodes can't
remember which one it was we did say
that there's no one really like Nolan
and we got some comments saying like
well James Cameron Martin's oh I saw
those
yeah I think what you meant to say was
like people that aren't Martin Scorsese
and James Cameron they're not from like
the 80s you know what I mean they've
come in this is sort of the the next
person who's like that you know your
next Spielberg
um and yeah Nolan seems to be absolutely
killing it I bet Warner Brothers if they
hadn't had this Barbie box office they'd
be absolutely just furious with
themselves because whoever whoever came
up with that idea for the day and date
HBO Max thing that annoyed Christopher
Nolan in the first place I think it was
Jason kylo I tell you he's not there
anymore but he would be in big trouble
um so the flash has also been announced
as being one of the biggest well the
biggest comic book movie flop of all
time May meaning that it's you know it's
worse than Mobius worse than the New
Mutants absolutely crazy thinking about
how badly it's done and Blue Beetle
following that is predicted to do
140 million to 170 million on a box
office of 105 million it's only at 46.3
million domestically at the moment
yeah and it's had a 61 percent
um second weekend drop off which is
pretty bad I've I heard a uh interesting
I was talking with some people from
but I was talking with some people at
Disney and they were saying that they
got a figure that was
that
you know because we have the actors who
are not able to promote stuff you know
Oppenheimer and Barbie were still able
to do their marketing runs like right up
until the strike happened for the actors
but there's on average a 15 decrease in
box office uh that that's what the
estimate is that because actors can't
promote I didn't realize it would be
that might not sound like a a huge
amount but it really is and I didn't
think it would even be that much I was
like oh apparently actors promoting
stuff is still
very very vital to the laptop experience
and I was thinking about that today
actually because I saw this um
calculation I was thinking I actually
thought is that right though but I think
what it is what I deduced Greg in the
end is that we're quite plugged into
what films are for example we know
months in advance if we're gonna go see
a movie um and we normally do it off the
trailers or you know just generally what
our audience is for example if it's a
comic book movie we're probably gonna go
see it just because our audience is
based around that and then I was
thinking like my grandma I do the
grandma test on a lot of things and my
grandma often doesn't hear about films
and then she'll ring me up and be like
oh I saw this actor on Graham Norton
talking about the new film so I think
she is sort of representative of the
general audience and how they learn
stuff from chat shows and they're not as
clued in as we are they don't know
release dates off by heart you know what
I mean and they just kind of hear about
movies Matt might see the trailer in in
the cinema and then they see the
interviews and they're like oh is that
out this week so yeah uh 15 quite a lot
you know quick maths if you if your
movie was gonna make a hundred million
it's gonna make 85 85 billion you've got
that in the end it's great math
so yeah I mean you can see how it shakes
out over time and hopefully the studios
will realize maybe the actors are
important now another thing that this
actually relates to that I was thinking
this is really stupid is they've delayed
June so June was gonna release this year
but they've now pushed it back to March
next year and I did see a lot of
comments being like well this is clearly
because Timothy chalamet and Florence
Pew and all because it's got quite a big
cast they're not going to be able to
promote it and the studio is really
banking on them being able to do that
which is why they pushed it back because
of the strikes now do you think it's a
good idea for them to delay June because
I don't and I'll I'll talk about why it
is in a bit
I mean they've already ramped up their
marketing campaign for it like I don't
think they need because at this point
they could have already released you
know I I've been checking already to see
like are the Dune tickets on sale are
the Dune tickets on sale didn't they
just drop their empire magazine big
promo plug that was meant to be full
yeah it is a conduit for that to be like
hey look out for your Dune tickets and
the movie is a sequel as well it's a
part two people have already it's not
it's not the same as if this was the
first if this was the first dune movie I
would understand the argument for it
much more and and then you were
messaging me telling me where they
pushed the release date to in March 2024
and then you followed it up with a crap
ton of other movies that are releasing
in March 2024 and I think a movie a a
movie like Dune I don't think you want
to release it in in March you want to
release that like between the summer to
winter time some yeah summer winter not
fall but like a time where people have
they have a time to go to the theaters
you know where people are people are off
work or off school whatever and I think
this release date push is not the wisest
and I don't think it's really dependent
on the actors promoting it I feel like
it would have been just fine because it
is one of those things where they were
already able to have their push the
marketing push was already happening and
it's a Word of Mouth Big theatrical IMAX
going experience and they also had all
the IMAX theaters I'm just realizing
right now they like they I think the
Marvels is now able to go in there and
take up the iMac screens but Dune is a
specific IMAX movie going experience
they shot it with IMAX cameras and now
they're not going to be I can't imagine
they're going to be able to have that
exclusivity for that many weeks the way
how a movie like Oppenheimer has been
able to greatly benefit from it and this
is where you come in and say even
smarter points than me or I'm like Ah
that's where you do the man Paul that's
why you're the man maybe
so yeah so being pushed to March this is
what the lineup of March 2024 looks like
Pixar's Elio or Elio March 1st the Fall
Guy March 1st a quiet day pla sorry a
quiet place day one
with part one I don't know if it's
called that a quiet place day one day
one part one it has been said that's
gonna be pushed back
um but that's March 8th Kung Fu Panda
for March 8th June 2 March 15th Snow
White March 22nd Mickey 17 March 29th
Ghostbusters afterlife sequel whatever
that's called March 29th and an angel
Studios film the shift that's gonna be
uh that's to be confirmed in March as
well it's way too busy that is way too
busy we saw how Mission Impossible
suffered from it that's way too busy
well even going back to March this year
I actually pulled up the lineup
um that we had and that was a month
where you might remember Ant-Man Quantum
Mania dropped in February and then March
was like Creed 3
um Evil Dead rise I think
John Wick
yeah I think screen might have been
um so I'll just quickly pull up the the
movie releases for you guys so Shazam 2
as well
um 65 that Adam Driver dinosaur film
Dungeons and Dragons as well so there
was a lot of things in March that
released
and we saw that not many of them really
performed that well John Wick did really
good but Dungeons and Dragons didn't
perform to the level that they were
expecting and it was a good movie as
well Shazam two you know DC in general
has just been dying all over the place
so that might not have had a crazy box
office anywhere else but it seems like
they're repeating the process again with
March next year where it's going to be
absolutely stacked and it's going to
have such an effect on these films and I
cannot understand why they've taken it
where it had a complete clear I think it
was a five-week run in IMAX screens with
no competition around it you know the
Marvels maybe but it wasn't an IMAX and
it just had a clear road to completely
that time of year as well it's a really
good time to push for Oscars and stuff
which now it's gonna be out of the
running for that and to have it move
from that time period to a time where
it's gonna probably at most get one week
of IMAX screenings before the next thing
comes along and that takes over it just
seems insane and it just seems stupidity
and it's all kind of stemming from these
strikes that the studios seem to be
negotiating on but not really going in
with everything that they really can to
dissolve the situation and it's a real
shame because I was I was really looking
forward to June 2 as well and I think
you know that first movie was it was
really good and it got hampered by the
day and date thing of HBO
um and yeah that really harmed it and
now I think it's just gonna be put to
March where March typically just isn't
really that good of a time to release
movies in any way it depends on the
movie like Scream 6 did really well but
Scream 6 weirdly makes sense I know it's
like that or October or the two times
you would release a movie like Scream
Scream Six makes sense to me
um even John Wick to a certain extent
makes sense to me but the but something
like Dune oh that that just reeks of
Summer movie or winter like if you gotta
go by the feeling too you know like
movies are an emotional going experience
it's a moving picture and you've got to
have that emotional Association to the
experience of going to the cinema and
and the seasonal time of that would do
is actually a lot more fitting uh to me
at least that's just my personal opinion
yeah and I think just in general the way
that a lot the studios don't realize
they're they're cannibalizing themselves
with these overblown budgets on stuff
and yeah I was watching a great video
the other day talking about I forgot the
channel unfortunately
um but I'll try and remember and leave
it as a pinned comment but they were
talking about how back in the day you
know these mega event movies
Blockbusters they're called because the
reason they have that name is because
people would line up around the block to
see them and it would just they'd be
major event films where the studio would
invest lots of money to make it this big
Summer Event thing this one picture
they'd put all our eggs into one basket
and because of that you had things like
Jaws Star Wars you know big movies The
Godfather and stuff like that you know
they weren't going crazy wild with the
budget but nowadays it seems like almost
every single film
they're spending over 250 million
dollars sometimes into the 300 million
dollars Zone and they're trying to make
these major event films every single
week and when you get to a point where
everything's a major event film there's
no longer major event films because
everything is just seen as the standard
and because of that they're just
cannibalizing themselves so much
Disney's lost a billion this year on
movies and it's because they've got such
overblown budgets where that they're
people in general don't go to the cinema
every single week no matter how good the
movie is like the release lineup is
they're not gonna go every single week
because it's not part of their their
habits as viewers you can make a hundred
great movies a year but they're not
gonna go see all of them and I've had to
skip out on some because it's like I
went to the movies one week and it's
been like oh well I've got to get child
care for the next one and every time I
go I've got to organizing so I can go to
the film and and review it and yeah it's
just life gets in the way for people and
I think they they hit a point now where
it's like there's so many of these films
and they're available on streaming
really really quickly you know we're in
a cost of living crisis as well so
people just can't afford to even go out
that often and spend as much money as
movie tickets cost and yeah it's just
getting to a point where I I thought
June was in a great place because it
didn't really have that much competition
around it the Marvels that was about it
it was competing against one of the film
and I think both people you know normal
people General audiences they could go
and see both films and not feel like
they're they're blowing all their money
um and to just see them move it from
there to a time where everything's like
really really packed I'm just I just
wonder what what the whole thing is and
time back to the original point of
actors promoting the movies and doing
the um this chat shows and stuff I don't
feel like it needed that and yeah I
think moving this is just a really
stupid move because it's also given
Disney an advantage as well you know the
Marvels is now going to IMAX wasn't
filmed for it but you know all you do is
remove those mat lines the black bars on
the screen and you've uh you've got an
IMAX movie there for you yeah I saw a
trailer for the Marvels in IMAX so they
can convert it where you can watch it
there and you get the sound but none of
it was intentionally filmed for it
although I'm wondering does it help if
there's one thing I think we all can
agree on when it comes to a certain
personality in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Brie Larson is an undeniable
divisive personality the second she says
and the last time I feel like people did
not get on her ass was when she was at I
don't know one of those film festivals
and someone asked her about the Johnny
Depp [__] and the way she handled that
people were like you know what maybe
Brie Larson is in this battle
disdain for pretty Larson than everyone
else really feels nor am I enamored by
The Woman by any means
um but I am I am wondering if there's
some type of benefit to it because I
think especially with Disney
you know like we've talked about Rachel
zegler and I feel I do feel like Rachel
zegler is greatly affecting Snow White
you know in this similar sense of how
Ezra Miller affected the flash
um even though Ezra Miller couldn't
speak you know the personality of Ezra
Miller created a lot of divine for
people and I think Rachel zegler is
doing the exact is doing something like
very damaging to Snow White
um with everything she's saying and
there's just something about Brie Larson
that we we see whenever she does
anything on the Internet it's just met
with so much crap right away so there
might be a slight benefit to them
releasing the Marvels were like we don't
have to worry about the pr with Brie
Larson on the internet we can actually
Dodge this and I feel like that'd be a
benefit but on the flip side I feel like
a mon villani is a massive benefit
especially for like certain
International markets and I think imman
vilani is a very much beloved uh
personality uh so I do think she would
have benefited it maybe Sam Jackson to a
certain extent uh but I I actually think
people have come around on Brie Larson
genuinely and I think Rachel zegler is
one of those reasons because
I'm gonna be honest yeah
yeah just reporting in general and we
saw this with the pandemic going into
the Ukraine war the the media cycle they
need a story to focus on to sell papers
that week and it's the same with
YouTubers and oh definitely you know you
need that personality that you can just
make videos about milk content and Brie
Larson was that I mean how many videos
have Brie Larson were there and let's be
honest let's be honest Greg fair enough
what one or two things might have been
worth a story but there were a lot of
the time it was just anything she did it
was like we'll have to make a video and
I think if we're being honest guys a lot
of it was because those videos were
getting views and therefore making money
and they thought well we're just gonna
make a story out of every anything that
she does because it's gonna make views
and make money and you know they decline
in popularity and then Brie Larson
completely to her credit I don't think
she's really just she's dealt with it so
well you know she's never thrown a
meltdown or
responded to it she's just kept herself
really classy and hasn't you know sunk
down to any level to to acknowledge it
and even things like the you know the
the Johnny Depp question she got asked
she's like why are you asking me and I
think people have just I think when
reporters and journalists when they go
after someone they will hit a point
where it's like oh no we actually
respect this person because they've
slugged it out with us even if they've
done nothing back or deserved it in the
first place and then what they realize
is that another person comes along that
gets all that attention and that they
can become the focus of the stories and
they can be the person that they make
lots of videos about and get lots of
views about and that is what Rachel
zegler has done and it's never like
and and she seems to be getting doing
the opposite of what Bree did which was
she's obviously stepped away from social
media and it's clear that it has become
an issue and you know I I I I felt bad
that video we made we didn't even really
go after her to be honest but I think
just putting a spotlight on someone in
general is you know it can stir up
negative things
um well I think Brie Larson
um she is especially like she's it's
she's very different than the Rachel
Ziegler because yeah the Rachel zeglers
are very much she still like says stuff
right whereas Brie Larson that hatred
just seemed to gestate for so remember
when she like launched her YouTube
channel and it just met with so much
crap when I was like yeah she hasn't
said anything bad for like because I
remember when she even did like [__]
uh what was that what's what uh the B
Between Two Ferns a spoof interview show
people were like [__] she seems so
uptight I'm like guys the whole point is
the celebrity is supposed to be uptight
but I feel like uh other interviews even
her hot one's interview I think went
over really well uh even via the
Internet you know so and I'd like to I
actually like her in uh The Fast and
Furious movie that she was in and uh you
know she's on other great work
as well but she kind of hits me as
someone who just doesn't really give a
[__] that much but like it probably did
originally when she blew up and got
massive because I can imagine it's such
a massive change on your life to be
honest to go from like making indie
films to then becoming the star of a
Marvel movie and then seeing all the
backlash from me I can imagine just
completely messes with you so
but yeah I think I think um do you think
Marvel's will hit a billion no I don't
think the Marvels will hit a billions no
Sexes sexist pure sex story
okay but can I give my reasons before
nope I I think I think it's just it's
just a one thing and it's pure sexism
yeah it's not because I think in general
I mean when was what was the last Marvel
movie to hit a billion was it no way
home I have no idea was there no way
Doctor Strange came close I think that
did 800 million Guardians did about 880
I think and yeah I think just in general
that kind of shows that these movies
aren't you know they used to be
guaranteed to hit a billion but at the
moment just the way that the audience is
going with Marvel in general you know
secret Invasion didn't get a million
viewers first week and stuff like that
and I think in general it's gonna be
very difficult for the this film to out
of the blue you know beat Ant-Man in the
WASP Quantum Mania beat Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness Guardians 3 I
think if Mo I think if the Marvels was
gonna hit a billion those movies would
have done it too so I think in general
that there's a certain state of the
market right now where Marvel movies
just aren't doing what they used to and
you know it might surprise every one I
would definitely be surprised I was
wrong about Barbie yeah you were
I'm I'm very wrong about Barbie clearly
championing for Marvels not only because
you reminded me of the Barbie thing I'm
now gonna Hardcore Champion and Marvel's
makes a billion dollars but in its
credit as well you know the models now
has iMac screens which are premium
tickets so it instantly makes money more
money off doing that and it's also no
longer competing with June 2. so it you
know it could do I don't even know what
the December movie releases look like
but it's it got way more of a stronger
chance now but I just don't think that
it will hit the billion and that's
purely because of just the interest of
Marvel in general and the way that all
of the other
MCU movies since no way home have been
at the box office as well I mean Ant-Man
the worst quantumania did that do 500
million or something yeah yeah
that did terrible yeah and and that was
starting off phase five uh that was
introducing Kang properly as well
obviously I know there was hints of him
with he who remains in the statue at the
end of local yeah but yeah I think just
in general the way the Market's going
for movies this year as a whole as well
um and obviously you know the Brie
Larson backlash is gonna probably come
into full swing I don't think it'll I'm
hoping it's not this bad this year and
I'm hoping we can have a nuanced
conversation about because we get pulled
into it as well and obviously there's
people who will label everything one way
are they there like if we say we like
something we've said it before we're a
shell if we say we don't like it we're
hey and it's the same if you say you
don't like a certain movie if if I say I
didn't enjoy the Marvels I'm gonna get
called a sexist I know for a fact and
even if I sit here and give reasons why
I didn't like it in there and then the
exact same reasons as I go for Ant-Man
and was quantumania say I'll still get
called the same thing and I think my I
think with Marvel in general people have
kind of almost realized like there's a
corporate I mean the face you know one
to three there was an idea that these
things were made by corporations and
stuff and there was a corporate
mentality to it but I think in the
latest phases you can really see the
corporate strings behind all these films
and how it's kind of like we have to do
this this is like Ant-Man in the WASP
Quantum Mania
it fine but yeah I I feel like when I'm
watching that I can see the the
cooperation behind it and the whole
everything in it just being like almost
like a product and I feel like viewers
are sort of becoming wise and and in
general like phase four just felt
formless and directionless I know that's
a criticism that gets lobbied at it a
lot but it just feels like the entire
face was just made for the sake of
making Marvel movies and they didn't
really have an idea of exactly where
they were going to go and they just kind
of did lots of different stories rather
than having the connected Universe they
once had and but yeah the models it
could surprise me but personally I I
just can't see a hit in the billion and
well you know how many movies have done
that this year it doesn't need to make
uh apparently I just looked it up it's
only its production budget is listed as
only 130 million dollars which is
actually relative this is from Forbes
um so that's relatively low
for a Marvel movie uh you know like yes
even if you need to make like what like
300 million to make a profit or
something like that that's actually not
yeah that's not bad okay they might have
a guaranteed hit on their hands if they
play their cards right
um but we should do you want to talk
quickly about before we go into the
writer strike about uh
this thing that from from Ultimate
scooper my time to shine hello has put
out that has stirred uh they put it uh
August 26th so Saturday
um in the U.S yeah can we say it's
breaking news and pretty yeah it just
came out Capital all Breaking
exclamation mark we got this
um I shall read it
it's my time to shine hello woman or a
guy I don't know do you know
let's go oh it is okay well a woman
stop being sexist on this podcast though
cut it out no screenwriters will be
hired for King Dynasty and Secret Wars
until the strikes are over
but it should I actually didn't read all
this but it should be Phil Lord and
Chris Miller
I'm pretty sure I'm not the first person
to suggest them and for good reason and
it crossed the spider verse they handled
280 variations of Spider-Man 95 okay
this is editorial here 95 of which are
unique and name characters yada yada
it's a great movie
um okay well that's interesting I mean
if I I will start with saying that I
think Phil Lord and Chris Miller I can I
get the argument for why they would be a
good choice
however I would still say don't do it
um because Phil Lord and Chris Miller
and their their co-writers on it on the
Spider-Man movies but they Thrive best
when they have a great amount of
producer creative control as well and I
don't feel like if anything has proven
itself within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that that unique voice they
would not allow them I mean they got
fired from freaking Star Wars which I
know like that's lucasfilm it's a
different department than Disney
but even within with even within the MCU
the way for Lord and Chris Miller if you
really want their voice to truly shine
you need them to have that creative
control as producers and it seems like
even with the spider-verse movies they
really allow them to do that it's Sony
it's Marvel it's still Marvel of course
but it's not the MCU
so I don't think I actually don't feel
like they're I wouldn't I personally
just wanted to like I get the dream
scenario but I I don't see it being a
thing where they can cooperate as we
were talking about corporations and all
that jazz that would totally intervene
um but the King Dynasty and strike of
Wars writers I mean they've been who who
was the writer for that do you remember
who they were it was the guy who wrote
quantumania right it was the writer did
like yes and was it
um Michael Waldron as well or was it
just Jeff Lupton yeah
Jeff loveness and Michael Waldron and so
I completely agree with what you said
about Lord and Miller you know they've
had issues with Disney in the past where
the whole thing with solo I I just can't
see them doing it and also you have to
bear in mind they're now they've done
three Multiverse movies in a row yeah
and they wrote the first into the
spider-verse as well didn't they I yeah
I think they were I mean there's still
co-writers on it though you know they
they get like all the credit but it's
they didn't even like direct those
movies you know and that's a big part of
it as well
yeah so I mean they yeah they so they
were yeah they did it um so yeah they've
they've done three in a row I mean are
they going to want to just jump into
another Marvel Multiverse movie
personally I don't think so and I think
the whole thing that you're saying about
creative control you're completely right
I don't think Sony had that much faith
in the spider-verse films and you know
it's an animated movie
uh it's often its own thing they didn't
promote it massively and it was more
sort of a sleeper here that did really
well on Netflix and yeah you know the
its sequels made the money and I think
they they uh solely got lots of creative
control because it was again animated so
you know things aren't as strict because
it's not as high of an expectation for
example if we did a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles live action movie versus an
animated one that we've just seen yeah I
think the animated one you're gonna get
more creative control and just get to do
what you want because there's not the
pressure on it and it was also not Peter
Parker it was a Miles Morales story as
well and I think Sony were just like oh
yeah you guys won our Miles Morales
animated Spider-Man movie that's totally
fine yeah go off do what you want
whatever we're not that bothered about
it and obviously then it became this big
hit when it's Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars you know what Marvel has been
building up to what they're good that's
going to be their next end game the
there's no way they're just gonna give
them the whole thing and be like hey go
off do what you want me whatever
whatever you think mate do you want and
I think they're well aware of that and I
think they've got enough
um
prowess in Hollywood now to they would
get given more creative control I think
because they've proven themselves but I
still don't see why they would want to
work in that environment when it's been
you know it's clear that a lot of people
Marvel always has the final say and for
example Thor love and thunder you know
Taiko or TT gets a lot of [__] for that
film
but from what I've heard you know it was
a much longer movie and they kind of cut
it down to two hours which was mandated
by Marvel and maybe there exists a
really really good cut of love and
thunder out there but we'll probably
never see it and yeah I just
even for those guys I'd rather see them
do something else than a Marvel movie I
feel like they've shown they can take
you know a pretty obscure you know Miles
Morales isn't a massively obscure
character he's still Spider-Man at the
end of the day but they've shown they
can take that an animated movie as well
and change how animations made and I'd
rather see them do it in another genre
rather than just like another Multiverse
movie for Marvel because I think that's
limiting what these guys can do and I
think they could really
knock it out the park with something
else and but obviously yeah Jeff
loveness and Michael Waldron have been
taken off that you know that might show
that marbles taking stuff seriously and
you know what I didn't talk about this
before but when you brought it up the
budget for the Marvels as well they've
not let that spiral out of control so
they're gonna make more profit from that
um which is a smart way to go you know
these these who was it was Charlemagne's
podcast where they were talking about
how endgame was the Super Bowl and then
for some reason Marvel kept thinking
they had to spend Super Bowl money on
their Saturday morning League stuff
I think more yeah I think Marvel's
finally starting to realize you know
these big mega event movies that's where
you put all the money in that's where
you get all the cast in and right these
little ones they don't need those crazy
overblown budgets where you need to
spend you know upwards of 250 million
because it's not it's not going to pay
out and even if the movie does well it's
it's still gonna seem like a flop
because snobby YouTubers will talk about
how little the the movie made I think um
just Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny I think that's really made
Disney realize like oh crap we are
spending far too much money on these
movies when we don't need to and if we
have more realistic expectations
um but yes Secret Wars is obviously
going to be the Super Bowl again and I
think you know loveness I I actually
like some of this stuff he did in
Quantum Mania I don't feel like that
film was his fault I feel the scenes
with Kang and Michelle Pfeiffer you can
really see why he was brought on to it
and I feel like it was probably Marvel
who were like well you've gotta make
Cassie Lang a big character in it and
it's like well yeah but it's called
Ant-Man and the WASP so yeah whatever
just make it about Scott and his
daughter
um you've got to have that stuff and he
said but I want to explore Kang in his
origin story and say well you can have
that scene we'll give you one scene
where you get to really explore that but
you better fill in that corporate [__]
and you better start selling some action
figures of that blob guy down in the
quantum verse well these Marvel movies
are very heavily committee made and even
Michael Waldron he was getting so much
crap for Multiverse and Madness it's
it's the way I mean the way the internet
works is like you you can do something
amazing like he was a showrunner uh for
Loki and then he does Multiverse Madness
and everyone was like this guy is [__]
and even zochi Gomez I remember she was
the one who came out on Twitter and was
defending the hell out of Michael
Waldron for Multiverse Madness because
he was getting shot on a bunch and she
was saying like you don't know the kind
of Demands they make last minute all the
time uh that the way like writers can be
The Fall Guys for some reason you know
if something's terrible they can they're
the last ones to get praised for these
for especially for the big movies like
the huge films they're the last ones to
get praised but they can also be one of
the first things to blame for why
something is crappy you know and like no
one ever really talks I I rarely hear
unless it's like written and directed by
them uh I I still have a hard time
recalling it maybe the no not even the
russos wrote uh this Captain America
movies Stephen mcfreely and Christopher
Marcus the the writers are never praised
for for their screenplays they're not
and I think endgame in an Infinity War
actually scripted really well so so is
you know Captain America Civil War and
uh Winter Soldier I think there's a
scripted very very well but you rarely
hear people talk about it's always about
the director but if a movie's not liked
they'd say it's the writer's fault and
what we all know like it's more than
just the rider like yeah it starts it's
supposed to start with a screenplay it
doesn't really happen that way at Marvel
we all know that it starts with a big
board of here's what you need to include
and here's what we need to get to and
now fill it in with some scenes so we
can finally get there and so yeah I
don't I don't feel like it's fair to put
it on them I am wondering if uh because
you know they got Matt this looks like
they're looking at some of their people
who did well with certain properties you
know you got the direct after getting
everyone's names the director of Shang
Chi who's doing King Dynasty and then
you have the uh the writer the
showrunner for one division who's doing
Fantastic Four
he was the showrun right I have the
shoulder him doing a Fantastic Four so
I'm wondering if
they're gonna maybe want him to do
Secret Wars or something like that like
I don't know who the ripe I don't at
this stage in the game I'm like I don't
know which screenwriter would be the
best fit like I I have no idea like
people say the russos maybe sure is
Christopher Marcus and Stephen mcfreely
maybe but then the day it's if there's
one thing that's really apparent within
Marvel it's that a lot of times it's not
really going to matter what's how good
of a screenplay it is they're probably
gonna go in there and be like change
this change this we need this we need
this we need this make this happen make
this happen make this happen and a lot
of it's going to be at the last minute
and if it's crap they blame them and if
it's not if it's great they're not going
to get any credit it's just the way it
goes
well I've seen a rumor this week talking
about
um James Gunn I mean he's obviously got
a massive name now but he apparently he
was he didn't want Star-Lord to go to
Earth until Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 because that was gonna be the point
where
they had this big closing of his Arc you
know from that first film when he got
abducted from the planet after his
mother died and got into the Galaxy vol
3 was where they were going to pay that
all off now this is all rumored it might
not be true but what happens in endgame
is that Star-Lord ends up on Earth and
just kind of looks around and then
leaves like I'm also pretty sure that
James Gunn didn't want Adam Warlock at
the end of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
but that got mandated as well
um and I feel like you know that thing
with Star-Lord kind of robbed where his
eventual Arc was going to go on Earth
and it just feels like the studio kind
of do what they want we know for a fact
they don't tell the other people working
on other projects what's happening on
certain things because there's been a
number of them that have come out and
said I had no idea what was working on
like what was happening in one division
because I didn't get to see it before or
know what was happening before we
started making this movie I think that's
a lot you know that's a big problem with
Marvel
um I just don't know what's going to
happen with Secret Wars you know I kind
of feel like they're trying to catch
lightning in a bottle again and I think
it's going to be very difficult you know
we've got so much controversy
surrounding it but from what I've heard
as well I mean if if the rumors about
Hugh Jackman Toby Maguire and Robert
Downey Jr being the three main leads in
it
it's going to just print money isn't it
it's like yeah
you're just saying that made me go that
sounds [__] awesome oh my God yeah I
don't even need to know the plot like
I'm there I'm automatically there need a
screen right there yeah let them
improvise yeah
but yeah obviously you know there's so
many issues in Hollywood at the moment
and that takes us into today's main
topic we're 43 minutes in 43 minutes in
we got here we got here yeah the strikes
so yeah
um there's been a lot of talks this week
the wga sat down to negotiate with the
ATM TP is it I always get the enemy at T
company uh amp TP
yeah and uh things haven't gone well so
there's been you know the strikes of uh
continued and there's been a lot of
backlash over it
um so the wga's proposal you know that
to be fair to the studio
um I'm actually going to stick up for
them a bit they did meet them on quite a
lot of the issues that they were were
after
um for example the AI you know those
talks about that uh they did give them
more residuals I think they raised their
pay as well but the main thing that I
came down to was the amount of writers
that were allowed to be like the minimum
amount of writers that had to be on a
project right um and that was where they
kind of clashed on it
um the mini the minute what was it
called the minimum staff versus the mini
rooms and all that
Yeah Yeah so basically they wanted more
people involved
um to help with the writing so it wasn't
as much crunch I think but but yeah just
having more people involved with it the
studio didn't want to do that at all
um and Bob igers came out and well they
say Bob iger's personally offended by it
and just looking at I've got a table of
the um the the money that they wanted
and
so the it's basically this lists all of
the studios how much the annual cost to
them would be and what their annual
revenues are now for example Disney the
annual revenue is 82 billion and the
cost that this would be to the right is
would be 72 million so as an example you
know it's 0.0 88 so it's not even one
percent of their annual revenue that
they would have to pay to the wga and
they're kind of dragging the heels on it
and just being like no I don't want to
do it it just seems so greedy it seems
so stupid I've said this on the podcast
so many times that they are gonna have
to like close this deal because
otherwise the industry's dead at some
point it's they have to do it and the
fact that they've started delaying
movies because of this now
it's insane to me it really is I just
don't understand what's going on and why
they've decided to go this way with it
and I and I I unfortunately the cynical
side of me sees it as them being like
well they can't go much longer it I
think the strike at this point is about
120 days into it when we release this
video roughly yeah and I think they're
just thinking you know at some point
they're going to be so desperate they'll
just take any deal that we give them and
I think they're just kind of playing
Hardball and trying to drag it on as
long as possible even though it's gonna
cost them in the long run probably
delaying movies
gonna see the same repeats of the box
office this year where we've got so many
films releasing so closely together with
such big budgets that there's no way
they can make their money back because
they're not gonna have their the
audience for as long as they deserve it
because people are going to be watching
it one week probably not going to repeat
viewings and going to the next thing the
next week and yeah it just seems really
stupid
what what's your opinion on a Greg
uh I feel like this Studios
because there was something that
um I listened to uh listen to Dan
Merle's video this morning and he
brought up a point that I thought was
very I mean like honestly damn I think
damn Earl's like the best at breaking
this stuff down right like he's amazing
at it uh I really if you guys don't
watch damn girl watch damn Earl
especially when it comes to these topics
because he'll like take all the Articles
and everything the things that I'm like
wow there's so much information here
um and yeah it really breaks down the
numbers and stuff and and one of the
initial points he brought up that I
thought was really really strong
which is true because when the like when
we first talked when we talked about the
writer strike a couple weeks ago we were
discussing how
they even said hey we got a meeting the
writer The Writer's Guild you know like
pretty much like the board of directors
the president not like everyone in the
writer's Guild just like the main people
in charge of the Union they had a
meeting with the amptp but they wanted
to not reveal their discussions to the
public they didn't want to reveal their
discussions uh to to even their writers
because they were like we know that they
can create like discourse and whatnot
and they just need to Hash this out
internally they need to negotiate and
that was part of the agreement that they
had which was to not disclose any of
this that they're doing and a big part
that is I I remember that clearly and it
was one of the things that did strike me
uh up unintended one of the things that
did you know kind of like oh it's kind
of weird that the amptp is putting this
out there because they released a
statement of hey guys we presented
something to the writers and look at us
we're offer the way they for the way
they phrase their language was you know
a by the Numbers good way to make them
look good and be like we offered them
stuff and it's better than before and
and they they put out all the they
literally released like you could find
the details of everything they they
really of what they offered as their
final negotiation and it wasn't supposed
to be a public statement and to me it
was kind of a like a Machiavellian
tactic that left like the writers
feeling quite
um uh uh beguiled uh those are my last
big words of the podcast by the way uh
I'm not even sure if I use those words
I'm pretty sure I use those words
correctly uh but yeah yeah I'll look it
up later no we can keep it in the video
I used them right but yeah they uh but
as it's because they it was supposed to
be an internal negotiation and it's Le
and it can leave people going like us
going well guys What The Hell Riders
fuss up that you got yourself a deal and
then everyone's getting their opinions
in there and none of the court of public
opinion right now actually matters in
terms of getting these negotiations just
settled and everyone is very
everyone right now is there's so much
it's a very acrimonious situation
everything is very sensitive between
them and then they're very reactive and
they should just be in the rooms hashing
the [__] out and then when the amptp
decided to do that I think it also it
just added on as just a much bigger
level of distrust because they weren't
part of the agreement was they weren't
supposed to release this [__] it was
supposed to be a negotiation internally
and then they got their right so then
that the big part of it of what the
writer's Guild was the members were
saying was the way they released that
was meant to help
um a manipulative tactic to create a
divide within the writers because
they're going to be some writers who
read this
and think wait I like this we should say
yes to this and there's gonna be other
writers who don't and then it creates a
discourse among them and the whole point
is to create is to keep the writers in
Harmony and create it's to be in unity
to be a union together and so I think of
the way the amptp went about it there
are a lot of like little little
loopholes they're making progress on
everything everything there is progress
on the main thing that we were talking
about of course
um like the mini rooms uh or the thing
that the writers are real the writers
are really trying to eliminate that and
to my understanding like how a mini room
essentially works is it's twofold if a
showrun if someone pitches like a
screenplay and they want to see if a oh
is there a chance that this this could
be a series uh let's hire like two to
three Riders to write like a couple of
episodes and it you know the they paid
them less than usual or sometimes it's
just for if they want to see if they
want to renew for another season and
these are writers who are not a they
can't work on anything else during this
time period and B they're paid less than
usual generally and see a big part of it
is they're not guaranteed to continue on
in this series so a lot of times they
can help create something
but then they're just let go afterwards
and they don't get to be a part of the
staff and so there seems to be I see I
see it online with a you know I listen
to quite a few videos about it where
even the opinions surrounding the
writer's room the writing staff the mini
rooms and whatnot
there are people who who are very much
going the writers shouldn't be arguing
about this and there are people who are
going the writer should be arguing for
this I actually do understand what the
problem is here for that because they're
trying to give Riders a chance
to feel a little bit more secure feel a
little bit more safe and then have an
opportunity because
if a writer cannot stay on board for a
show to be a part of the production
process the post-production process it
never gives them an opportunity to
become like a showrunner or get even
consistent gigs it really affects their
career and business because like actors
writing is also in its own way its own
kind of audition process on top of that
too so there's barely any progress on on
that part the AI it's like they've had
no when you read this stuff the amptv
says sometimes it sounds like
oh they've made progress then when you
break it down you're like they actually
haven't made any progress on what's been
said here and especially regarding the
use of AI because a lot of it can be
very flowery language to the point where
it can sound like one thing but when you
really decipher it especially regarding
AI they don't really have much progress
in that department where you're like
okay they the writers are they're trying
to even understand how they themselves
can find some type of structure where
they can innovate some type of AI
because there's camps where they don't
want AI whatsoever and then there's this
other side of is there a way we can
reasonably figure out how we can
incorporate AI in some capacity that is
not about them just writing the
screenplay themselves
and the pushback from if the amptp is to
me it just sounded like
we can revisit this in a couple of years
but we want to still have this be a part
of the inclusion in the conversation and
to me I understand the fear of that you
know of because now what was the thing
you I'm sure you've heard about it that
the AI scripts if it's just a purely AI
generated script that cannot be
copyrighted in order for it to be
copyrighted there has to be at least a
human rewrite on it in some way
yeah so that yeah you can't copyright an
AI written script because all it is is a
prompter you not really come up with it
and someone else could randomly do the
same prompt and come up with the exact
same thing and then if a studio say I
just type the same prompt as a studio
gives me the same script and then the
studio release a movie and I could
potentially have made that script before
the studio like released the film and I
could go to a court and be like look
mate this is my copyright I've got the
date on the script I I wrote if it was
my script first so we're suing Disney
um so yeah you obviously you can't
copyright AI created work and what they
were going to do was in order to bypass
that was get the script written by Ai
and then pay someone a very low age to
come in and just tidy some things up
change some things about and then that
makes it copyrightable so yeah that was
another way where they're just kind of
screwing workers out of it I think going
you know going public with the terms was
just so bad because the thing with
unions is if you sign up to a union your
part and parcel with them you know
you've got to take the good and the bad
with it and one of the bad things is
that if if a union goes in and
negotiates with an organization they
don't really put those things to a vote
and they they'll often make the decision
for you to to try and get you the best
deal or and in some ways they're going
to lose out on some things and whatever
but
dampering out the terms of the deal it's
it's purely done just to
you know cause friction and you
completely write it because I've seen
the the way that public opinions swayed
online and a lot of people are saying
you know they've agreed to 80 of the
terms
it's a good deal the writers are now
greedy for not taking it and the wga is
greedy for not taking it and it's kind
of like that's clearly being put out to
so dissent because they have agreed to a
lot of things and you know I'm not a
writer so I can't like on paper
sure it seems like it's it's a good deal
and you know it seems like like I I even
thought as much as I bashed the studios
I did think you know they they've taken
on board some things and and are trying
to work around it but I'm not a writer
so I can't fully grasp the situation and
be like well is it actually a good deal
you know what I mean the situations
where I I like you you just not if
you're not in the position yourself
you'll have no grasp of what it actually
means and you'll just be looking and and
one of those things that that's come up
actually from that discussion is
someone's at some point this week said
that writers get paid eleven thousand
dollars a week to work on a TV show now
there's been a lot of people who've
taken that and thought oh they must make
eleven thousand dollars a week for the
whole year and that's not the case
they'll work on a show for for maybe
three or four weeks or something and
they'll get eleven thousand dollars for
those weeks then they then gotta live
off that for the rest of the year so
it's not a stable job and you're
constantly looking for work and there's
just these things that are getting put
out and it you know it
not to be the guy who's like the I can
see things from both sides but it's
clear that a lot of things are getting
put out into the public eye that are
turning people against the studios and
turning people against the strikers and
these guys have got to work together at
the end of the day and they have they
have to come to a certain point you know
both sides are going to have to give up
something at some point and both sides
are gonna have to gain something I think
it's good they're making Headway but
personally
I I do lean more towards the the writers
and the actors in terms of what I think
they're getting
um I I did like the maths on what the
the strikers were asking for and
it was something like two episodes of
secret Invasion would cover all of the
writers for an entire year
um one day of Barbie pulled in enough
for for Warner Brothers to pay
you know pay the writers Universal that
they could probably make theirs from
copyright claiming YouTubers and there's
no way yeah apple all the writers want
from Apple is 17 million and there's no
way that apple don't have 17 million
lying around I can tell you that for
free right now Greg that is chump change
to those guys they will have that money
they're probably wasted that money on
something on an accounting error or
something yeah um and it just seems like
they're
just in general corporations do this a
lot when people ask for more money I've
I've talked about in the past with my
job experience when I've asked for
raises and they've said no and it's been
like well
I'll see them wasting money on buying an
extra TV for the office that they don't
need and that just get never gets turned
on and gets thrown out in the trash
um and yeah it for the amount of money
that Hollywood wastes
you're throwing it all into one thing
and then there's people in the corner
who aren't making enough to live on and
it's kind of like yeah just just think
about it please because you're going to
destroy the industry if you don't so
yeah it's all over the place and and
they've still got to negotiate with the
actors as well yeah I think the I think
those writers who got I forget exactly
how the percentage breakdown goes down
when the big numbers got released of uh
they offered them like 11 000 a week or
something like that because it's all
dependent on how many weeks you're
contractually obligated to be a part of
this show and yada yada
and I believe that is for the article 14
writers which I only recently learned
about which article 14 writers it's not
it's not most of the writers on on the
staff on the staff article 14 writers
are the ones who also have like
additional credits like uh like a
showrunner or or is also like a producer
or a story editor or something like that
so we're they're trying to the the wga
is trying to look after up-and-coming
writers people who are new writers and
then your average writer and not just
your special writers you know and and
that's the big part of the protection
game here and so I I am definitely more
on on the writer's side there's not
there's not too much that I've heard I
can't even really think of anything off
the top of my head where I'm like
what I what I'm curious to hear when it
sounds like us the public are never
going to get
we're never gonna get it I'm very
curious to hear
one day down the road what the residuals
how they're going to factor that out
because the amptp offered some type of
crazy thing of
we're gonna have a private meeting like
every once in a while with like the
heads the wga
where we will reveal the numbers for uh
streaming video on demand we will reveal
those numbers and then we can negotiate
we can figure something out and it'll be
like a periodic thing that we can do but
it wouldn't be something that if I'm
just a writer on I don't know some
random show I hardly Quinn if I'm one of
the main writers on Harley Quinn or
whatever I wouldn't get access to those
numbers so that way I can have my agents
negotiate on my behalf to see what my
contribution is and how much I'm
entitled to and all that jazz uh so even
even for them they're they're really
they're really hiding their residual the
the streaming numbers like so hardcore
they are hiding they are they're
fighting tooth and nail to to hide that
and the conversation around residuals
yeah they
the I get the residuals should be higher
to me I I have no real way of possibly
having a strong opinion on I don't know
what that percentage should be though I
I really don't because I have no idea
what the hell there is what the
streaming numbers actually are on
anything and most and and the studios
are doing whatever they can to make sure
that information does not get released
uh so as much as they'll release all
this [__] they're they're not going to
release whatever this the SVO papers are
and I and I feel like too like because
there's two camps for the streaming
right there's there's the video on
demand which is when you buy it you know
like that's probably what I'm going to
be doing September 5th when Barbie comes
out I'm gonna buy it and watch it so I
can cover it
um
and then and then of course there's
there's when it goes to like Netflix or
HBO Max or or whatever it's called
maximum or if when it goes there that's
a that's a different department and a
different kind of streaming number you
gotta factor in versus I think they
should be entitled to something if if
people are buying it like myself when I
spend like 25 to buy meg2 you know that
there should be some type of little pay
I don't know what it would be like 50
cents or some [__] but depending on how
many people are buying
um are buying that you know uh it's also
complicated I have no way of doing of
possibly having a strong opinion on it
but I would like to know
I feel like they don't tell the
streaming numbers because they're so bad
exactly genuinely think that a lot of
the time and because we've seen in the
past when a showed as well they shouted
from the rooftops are like oh how's the
Dragon episode one had 25 million
viewers yeah um whereas when they don't
do it and you know stuff like Willow
gets removed from Disney plus six months
after it gets released right I think a
lot of the time that the studio would be
embarrassed to to put out these numbers
that the shows get
um so I think they hold them back you
know we I mean we do actually have a
fair kind of gauge because we can tell
what the interest in the show is like
for example I I don't know the final
figures for Ahsoka just yet but just
going off the views I've got in
comparison to other shows I can kind of
Judge the popularity from it and it's
the same with trailers whenever we do
exactly a reaction or a trailer
breakdown we can normally tell in
advance whether a movie is going to be
popular and whether this interest in it
now they'll often be some things that
you know are unexpected hits and you
just can't you can't get it but like I I
I've known stuff's gonna bomb months in
advance and it's purely because of how
badly the trailer reaction's done and
how Indiana Jones perfect example yeah
and our I would say I always try and aim
for a hundred thousand views on a
trailer breakdown at least at least
Marvel you're normally up in the half a
million bracket
um and you know that that's the hype for
me so I sent you a message the other
week of um when it was the Spider-Man no
way home trailer and it was like a
million views in nine hours on yeah my
breakdown of it which weirdly you were
like It's Gonna flop and I was like what
do you mean it's Gonna Fly
so so new straightaway yeah Spider-Man
no way home is going to be a big movie
but on the opposite side of this Indiana
Jones 27 000 views on a trailer
breakdown so you can kind of see the
difference between that and we do have a
rough idea of how well stuff's doing
um and a lot of the time I feel like the
studios don't do because it's
embarrassing we have to ride out with
our views on our chest Greg like if if
our video bombs the world has to see it
but obviously they've got residuals
money and investors involved and stuff
like that and it's probably better for
them to just be like well red noticed it
really well it was the most popular
movie in the world what's the what's the
viewing figures on that
um really good
19 billion so yeah
so yeah it's I think they're playing
coin I think this is going to be
something that they always play Kai with
and it's purely to save face if
something does badly because you know
for a fact if something does well that
that just throwing the numbers out there
saying how popular it was
um it's the number one show in the world
that that after that tagline always
makes me laugh it's the number one show
or the number one movie in the world
because a lot of the time yeah most
movies debut at number one in the world
if they're yeah you know if they've got
a good push behind the studio
um and they're a big franchise so yeah
that stuff always makes me laugh uh what
was the Black Adam trailer I'm sure the
Rock
but it so it was something like Black
Adam is the most positively reviewed
trailer of all time yeah so what the
hell does that even mean something along
those lines I need to find the full
quote
um
Rotten Tomatoes score for trailers
um okay so two words hashtag Black Adam
thank you around the world a staggering
98 positive Global review for our Black
Adam trailer what does that even mean
Greg so I've been in the trailer game a
long time and I've got no idea what that
means a
98.
what a weird way
so yeah rather than releasing the actual
viewing figures for stuff they'll uh
they'll often put things out like that
it's like and they do it all the time
where it's like it's the most popular
movie released on Labor Day weekend
starring a woman who written written the
first draft of it three years ago in the
future and they try and spin it
positively but when you've got the the
you could be like Blue Beetle the next
trailer could be the number one movie in
America you know it's it's as simple as
that just saying that [__] when you're
like but if you look at it it ain't
doing well you know and it's like that
for a lot of number one movies
yeah the numbers don't lie men lie women
lie numbers don't and I think they put
their spit on stuff because you know it
makes it sound positive and it makes it
sound successful but if you sat down and
looked at the numbers you'd often be
like well this is pretty [__] and then
what happens off the back of that is
your stock might dip for example say the
number one Netflix movie in the world
it's the biggest hit that Netflix have
had on the 15th of March 2024 it's world
record break-in yeah and then if you sat
down and looked at the number event it
was like 3 000 people have watched it
boo they're stuck mate that's gonna just
tank straight away because they're gonna
be like well so that's the movie they're
bragging about therefore it has a
knock-on effect of everything and be
like well all the movies they've bragged
about in the past how successful they've
been they've obviously not been that
successful and thus it tanks the entire
stock now this stock tanking is
something that we can see live and yet
Disney after the after the meeting went
pretty badly with the wga their shares
yeah their shares actually closed lower
than 84 and so the shares were 83.11
um dollars all together so 83.11 which
is the lowest that it's been since
October 17
2014. so I mean the graph if you look at
it Greg it's just like
literally it goes along there you can
see where the meeting happens boom Drop
Dead uh so yeah it's clearly not went
well for the studio and
yeah I think they're just stupidity
greedy greedy I was gonna say greedity
there stupidity and greed have just cost
them everything and Tony Gilroy actually
came out this week and said the Studios
have almost nothing in common but greed
we have what we have one problem the
amptp does not have their [__] together
they do not know they do not know who
they're [__] with sorry guys it's 10
o'clock at night and I'm normally in bed
by about seven but uh yeah I'm
mispronouncing stuff all over the place
but and he said go watch and or season
two when it's out
yeah highest grossing Star Wars show
released on a Tuesday evening at 6 p.m
in Brazil
uh so yeah that'll be no doubt something
I'm sure I sent you a screenshot this
week of like Ahsoka uh we need to pull
up the coil that they're using in the
trailer because it's so funny
um just talking about the Star Wars
shows it's kind of like so this is the
the tagline that they're using to
promote a soccer with the Star Wars show
you've been waiting for it's like yeah
what are you in about mate are you
saying all the other ones were [__] I
thought Mandalorian Caesar one and two
are really good
yeah it's it
yeah I love dando I thought it was
brilliant
um yeah it's it's kind of weird how
stuff's changing with streaming and I I
feel the studio is trying to gain more
control over their numbers and because
back in the day you know you had network
television they had to report it a lot
of the time I feel
um they obviously had third parties
negotiating it um Channel networks and
so on who would buy the shows and then
show them and they would get the figures
from that whereas when it's an in-house
streaming service that they own they
control all that so we're not getting
the numbers on it and clearly you know
that has an effect on residuals for
example tsg are suing Disney
um for for Under reporting figures and
there is the potential that they could
do the same with residuals and just say
well this streaming show hasn't done
very well they'll say that behind closed
doors and be like and that's why we're
not paying you money guys but in in
front of everyone they'll be like it's
the biggest show in the world yeah it's
bigger than School games third weekend
so yeah very strange uh very strange
place to be in at the moment I'm hoping
that this gets resolved quickly and then
they just
resolved the active stuff quickly as
well because I mean if they're losing 15
on box offices
purely because the Stars can't promote
it that's hurting a lot of the the back
end of films
and we just need to get back to filming
man Hugh Jackman can only stay in shape
for so long for Wolverine we need
Deadpool 3 filmed he's probably on like
a die of an apple and maybe like a bowl
of muesli a day just to stay ripped as
[__] so I feel bad for the guy
do you remember when they did Justice
League and you could tell they'd brought
Ben Affleck in for reshoots and he was
just like loaded yeah yeah I don't want
to body shame the guy but you could tell
they dare he trained really hard to
shoot this stuff for Zack Snyder and
then he'd be like finally that's over
I'm going straight to the diner I'm
gonna pig out and enjoy myself and then
they're like oh can you be here can you
be back in and shoot the entire movie
again from the ground up please
I saw Ben Affleck in person at the Flash
and away he
I did that thing where he he got out of
the limo and he was he was like
literally about to pass me
and I was like oh my God it's been out
like I'm gonna take out my my phone
he made a split second of contact with
my phone
and I immediately took my phone away
because I was like I've I'm so scared of
these guys he's actually I thought of
every video right in that moment I got
like a array of flashes of every single
time Ben Affleck has been mad at someone
recording him or trying to just eat his
Dunkin Donuts while smoking a cigarette
but in person yeah I did see him up
close again
he is a truly handsome gentleman he's a
absolutely yes I love Ben no he's a
great guy I could see he he has that
thing where you're you see him and
you're like oh that is a celebrity like
you just see you you see it like that is
a that that is what they call a
Hollywood star right there like he's
he's got that that presence about him
and my silly mind Jennifer Lopez was
next to him both times and I never even
looked at her once the entire time I
didn't even glance at people were like
do you see Jay like oh yeah yeah she was
there but I didn't even bother to like
take a glance at her it was just bad app
like I was staring actually
I actually know as Jenny From the Block
so I was like I probably wouldn't have
seen her as a celebrity because she's so
down to earth and she's just she's just
Jenny from the box
so yeah don't be fooled by the Rocks I
just got she's still she's still Jenny
From the Block
um but yeah lovely little story to end
Ender on I'll tell you what you know
that um that live show I did the other
week with uh talking about social media
or Edinburgh Fringe yeah I was talking
to the guy behind it Darren he uh he
he's the host really nice guy but he um
said I almost had you on with Grant
Morrison but I thought you'd just fan
girl out about it and I was literally
like a smile that went oh yeah I
probably would have but deep down I was
like oh man I would have loved to just
sit and chat [__] with Grant Morrison
for like an hour yeah it didn't happen
oh so sorry
both both have celebrity stories there
where we didn't didn't wasn't meant to
be didn't act on anything nothing
nothing happened
we had almost celebrities birth
yeah I'll call our Jenny because she's
real what you get is what you see
and she'll tell tell me about how it's
crazy how a moment can just change your
life
anyway well that end the podcast there
so thanks again for listening to this
week it's not there's not been much
there's not really been much news as
there and we're suffering wait there's
been an hour UV News podcast 15 minutes
of news today we've we will stretch this
[__] out for as long as we can we know
we know how to do it we know how to
ramble just
it's just all opinions and I often say
opinion based news is opinion based
because there's not actually any facts
which uh yeah so that so thanks again
guys um
[Laughter]
that's gonna be the opener of every one
of them yeah so we hope you've had a
good time you know there's lots of
things to discuss we'd love to hear your
opinion in the comments below um you can
listen to us on the go at Spotify
Amazon podcasts Apple podcasts we're on
the mall I'd sometimes I just go for a
walk and just listen to myself I'll skip
through the Greg bits and my oh does
what am I saying this rubbish it sounds
terrible
um I'm gonna get myself canceled but I
feel like we've had an all right show
there considering how little stuff that
was to talk about we'd of course love to
hear you guys tell us some intelligent
stuff correct us when we're wrong which
is probably a lot break the figures out
show us what's happening
um yeah we love you guys thank you for
all your support thank you for making
this the number one podcast recorded on
a Sunday night at
10 p.m in the UK across the world global
worldwide between two people one from
England one from America it's been a
crazy break in all these records and yet
Greg any last words this week nah man
um this is this is perfect I think this
was perfect I appreciate you readjusting
one day we'll get one day we'll just
have like a day off and we'll and then
we'll just be filled with anxiety for
how behind we are because we decided to
have that day off I know how we are
that's that's what will happen
was thank you guys for being here
welcome you to open arms some of you and
uh Christopher Nolan's the only director
out there there's no other director Emma
all right
we're done we did a phone